vítej zpět u kurzu Pochopení kvantové informace a výpočtů, jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický
ředitel pro vzdělávání v IBM Quantum. Toto je eth lekce série a poslední lekce v
druhé jednotce série, která se věnuje kvantovým algoritmům. Hovořili jsme o dotazovacím modelu výpočtů včetně kvantových
algoritmů, které nabízejí prokazatelné výhody oproti klasickým algoritmům v rámci tohoto modelu. Diskutovali jsme o základních konceptech spojených s
kvantovými algoritmy a o tom, jak měřit výpočetní náklady. V předchozí lekci jsme probrali fázovou estimaci a Shorův
algoritmus. V této lekci probereme Groverův algoritmus, který poskytuje kvadratickou výhodu kvantových před
klasickými algoritmy pro tzv. nestrukturované vyhledávací problémy, které popíši, jakmile se do
lekce ponoříme. To jsou všechno základní témata týkající se kvantových algoritmů. Existují i další kvantové
algoritmy a obecná paradigmata, která různé kvantové algoritmy a kvantové algoritmické techniky spojují, a
pokud tě to zajímá, doporučuji ti podívat se na quantum algorithm Zoo, který kategorizuje známé kvantové algoritmy a obsahuje mnoho odkazů
na původní výzkumné práce, které přispěly k jejich rozvoji. V této sérii se ale
budeme držet základů, a od příští lekce přejdeme na nové téma. Ale
nejprve si povídejme o Groverově algoritmu. Zde je přehled lekce: začneme krátkým pojednáním o
výpočetním problému, kterým se budeme zabývat, a tím je nestrukturované vyhledávání. Intuitivně řečeno si
nestrukturovaný vyhledávací problém lze představit jako prohledávání kolekce položek, které nejsou seřazeny a nebyly uspořádány užitečným
způsobem. Poté probereme Groverův algoritmus, což je kvantový algoritmus nabízející kvadratickou výhodu oproti
klasickým algoritmům, a brzy si upřesníme, co to přesně znamená. Velmi stručný popis,
jak tento algoritmus funguje, je následující: nejprve probíhá inicializační krok a poté je operace, kterou budu nazývat
Groverova operace, iterována určitý počet krát, a nakonec proběhne měření, které odhalí kandidátní
řešení vyhledávacího problému. Vysvětlím, co je Groverova operace a jak ji lze
implementovat na kvantovém počítači, a poté projdeme analýzu této operace, abychom lépe pochopili, co dělá a proč je užitečná pro
vyhledávání. Třetí část lekce se věnuje počtu iterací
v Groverově algoritmu, neboli počtu aplikací Groverovy operace, za předpokladu, že si přejeme
maximalizovat pravděpodobnost, že algoritmus uspěje v nalezení hledaného prvku, a zároveň minimalizovat jeho
náklady. Začneme se speciálním případem unikátního vyhledávacího problému, kdy existuje právě jedno řešení,
a pak zvážíme, co se stane, když je řešení více. Nakonec lekci zakončím
několika stručnými poznámkami o Groverově algoritmu a jeho generalizacích. Začněme s
výpočetním problémem, který budeme v průběhu lekce řešit. Jako obvykle budeme
označovat Sigma binární abecedu a tuto notaci budeme používat po celou dobu lekce, takže to nebudu opakovat.
Předpokládejme, že máme funkci f, která zobrazuje binární řetězce délky n do
binární abecedy. Náš předpoklad je, že tuto funkci lze snadno vyhodnotit:
například možná máme Booleovský circuit pro tuto funkci, jehož velikost je polynomiální v n. To neznamená, že je to
nutně jednoduchá funkce v jakémkoli smyslu, nebo že ji obzvlášť dobře rozumíme. Například možná máme dost
komplikovaný a složitý Booleovský circuit pro výpočet f, který nám umožňuje ho vyhodnotit na různých vstupních řetězcích, ale nemá nutně
pěkný tvar navržený tak, aby nám usnadnil život. Naším cílem je najít řešení, čímž
myslíme binární řetězec délky n, pro který se f vyhodnotí na jedničku. Obecně je to velmi obtížný
výpočetní problém, nebo přinejmenším tak to předpokládáme. Zejména pokud vstupem je ve skutečnosti
popis Booleovského circuit pro výpočet funkce f, pak jde o tzv. NP-úplný problém. Jedním způsobem,
jak tento problém formalizovat, je jako dotazovací problém, a pro účely této lekce je rozumné
přemýšlet o tomto problému čistě v kontextu dotazovacího modelu. Ale když přemýšlíme o tom, kde nebo kdy tento
problém v praxi nastane, je pravděpodobně přirozenější uvažovat o f jako o funkci vypočítané Booleovským
circuit. Jak jsme ale viděli v lekci šest, tyto dva pohledy lze propojit konstrukcí, kterou jsme prošli pro vzití Booleovského circuit a
jeho převod na kvantový circuit pro implementaci dotazovací operace nebo dotazovacího gate. V každém případě, pojmově řečeno,
vstupem problému je tato funkce f a my hledáme řešení, pokud existuje. Pokud
řešení neexistuje, totiž pokud se f ukáže být konstantní nulovou funkcí, pak správným výstupem je hlásit,
že neexistují žádná řešení. Jde o nestrukturovaný vyhledávací problém v tom smyslu, že na f
není nic zvláštního, co by usnadňovalo nalezení řešení. Není to tak, že bychom prohledávali
data, která jsou již seřazena nebo nahrána do nějaké datové struktury usnadňující vyhledávání, a funkce f nenese žádné sliby,
které by nám pomohly. Jeden způsob, jak to pochopit, je, že je to jako hledat konkrétní
telefonní číslo v telefonním seznamu, na rozdíl od hledání jména, což je mnohem jednodušší, za předpokladu, že jména jsou
abecedně seřazena. V praktickém smyslu to není opravdu o prohledávání dat,
která obvykle organizujeme a ukládáme způsobem, který vyhledávání usnadňuje. Je to spíše reprezentativní pro hledání
řešení komplikované rovnice nebo snad hledání kombinace, která otevírá
zámek. Mimochodem, má smysl uvažovat o tomto problému v kontextu dotazovacího modelu bez ohledu na to, jak
vnímáme praktickou relevanci tohoto modelu. V reálném životě samozřejmě neexistují orákula nebo černé skříňky, ale dokud se
nenaučíme něco jiného, komplikované a záhadné Booleovské circuit jsou trochu jako černé
skříňky. Nyní si povídejme o algoritmech pro řešení tohoto nestrukturovaného vyhledávacího problému a budeme to dělat
v dotazovacím modelu jen pro jednoduchost. Pokud máme Booleovský circuit pro naši funkci místo černé skříňky,
můžeme stále na něm spouštět dotazovací algoritmy, ale samozřejmě nemůžeme vyloučit možnost, že pro tento problém bude
objeven nový algoritmus, který není založen na dotazech. Tím se ale nebudeme zabývat.
Nejprve trochu notace: celkový počet vstupních řetězců funkce f je 2 na
WEBVTT
malé n, kde malé n je délka vstupních řetězců funkce f. Dále budu označovat velké N tímto číslem 2 na
malé n. Je dost běžné, že lidé používají velké písmeno takto k označení dvě na mocninu malé
verze tohoto písmena. O čísle velké N budeme mluvit dost často, takže to bude
pohodlné a pomůže to udržet věci trochu úhledněji. A opět, tato notace platí pro
celou lekci. Samozřejmě můžeme vyhledávací problém řešit klasicky jednoduše
iterováním přes všechny možné n-bitové řetězce v libovolném pořadí a vyhodnocením f na každém z nich.
Pokud kdykoliv najdeme řešení, můžeme zastavit. V nejhorším případě ale vyhodnotíme f na každém
vstupním řetězci, takže to vyžaduje N, tedy velké N,
dotazů. Náklady tohoto výpočtu bychom mohli měřit jiným způsobem, nejen počtem dotazů. Ale počet dotazů
představuje počet vyhodnocení funkce f a je rozumné očekávat, že vyhodnocení f budou dominovat nákladům
tohoto výpočtu. To je ve skutečnosti nejlepší, co lze s deterministickým algoritmem udělat,
a opět, to je v kontextu dotazovacího modelu. Pokud jsme se dotázali na každý vstupní
řetězec kromě jednoho a f vzala hodnotu nula na všech z nich, jak si můžeme být jisti, že poslední
řetězec není řešením? Odpověď je, že nemůžeme, takže v nejhorším případě opravdu potřebujeme všech N dotazů.
Mohli bychom také využít náhodnost, která může nabídnout drobná zlepšení, jako je snížení
očekávaného počtu potřebných dotazů pro nalezení řešení, pokud existuje, nebo bychom mohli efektivně vyměnit pravděpodobnost správnosti
za snížení počtu dotazů. Ale jakkoli se na to díváme, stále potřebujeme počet dotazů lineárně závislý
na N. Klasicky tedy potřebujeme lineární počet dotazů, totiž lineárně
závislý na velkém N. Groverův algoritmus je kvantový algoritmus pro vyhledávání, který si vede lépe – vyžaduje jen O(
odmocnina z N) dotazů. Tyto dotazy probíhají v superpozici, takže to není kouzlo, ale
je to významné zlepšení oproti tomu, co je klasicky možné, a to je to, co se myslí kvadratickou
výhodou. Lze tuto kvadratickou výhodu kvantového počítání nad klasickým proměnit ve skutečnou výhodu v praktickém
smyslu? Pravděpodobně ne v blízké budoucnosti, ale v daleké budoucnosti kdo ví. Ale i kdyby
Groverův algoritmus nikdy nepřinesl praktickou výhodu pro vyhledávání, přesto je důležitou součástí
základů kvantových algoritmů, které stojí za pochopení. Než přejdeme k samotnému Groverovu algoritmu, musíme
stručně pohovořit o tzv. fázových dotazovacích gate. Mnoho kvantových algoritmů v dotazovacím modelu je přirozeně vyjádřeno
pomocí fázových dotazovacích gate a uvidíme, že Groverův algoritmus je konkrétním
příkladem. Začněme rychlým pohledem na obyčejné dotazovací gate pro funkci f
ve tvaru, o němž jsme mluvili. Dotazovací gate UF je definován na standardních bázových stavech tak, jak je zobrazeno na
obrazovce, a pro superpozice standardních bázových stavů je akce určena linearitou. Stojí za připomenutí,
že z Booleovského circuit pro f můžeme skutečně sestrojit circuit pro tuto operaci UF za cenu, která je
lineárně závislá na velikosti Booleovského circuit. Fázový dotazovací gate pro f, naproti tomu, označovaný
názvem ZF, funguje takto: zejména tento gate operuje na
malém n qubitech, na rozdíl od malého n plus jeden qubitů, a v podstatě jen automaticky přesouvá hodnotu funkce
do fáze, místo aby XORoval výstupní hodnotu na další qubit, jak máme pro
UF. Takže pokud si představíme, co se stane, když použijeme fázový kickback na gate UF,
v podstatě jen implementujeme gate ZF. Potřebujeme stav mínus a stojí to jedno
vyhodnocení UF, ale stav mínus zpět dostaneme a můžeme ho použít pro příště, pokud chceme, nebo
ho prostě zahodíme. To je tedy fázový dotazovací gate. Nyní, pokud nám je
dán pouze fázový dotazovací gate ZF a to je jediný způsob, jakým máme přístup k funkci f, nemůžeme skutečně
obnovit gate UF. Ale pokud máme řízenou verzi ZF, pak
gate UF sestrojit lze, a nechám to pro tebe jako
cvičení. Kromě fázového dotazovacího gate pro funkci f budeme také potřebovat fázový dotazovací gate pro n-bitovou
funkci OR, neboli jinými slovy funkci, která nabývá hodnoty nula pro řetězec samých nul a jinak nabývá
hodnoty jedna. Explicitně, způsob, jakým ZOR funguje na standardních bázových stavech, je zobrazen
zde na obrazovce. Tento gate nezávisí na funkci f, takže nevyžaduje
žádné dotazy. Jedním způsobem, jak sestrojit kvantový circuit implementující tuto operaci, je udělat něco
podobného, jako jsme dělali pro funkci f, až na to, že začínáme s Booleovským circuit, který počítá funkci OR na
n bitech. A nyní, když máme tyto gate, jsme připraveni přejít k další
části. Nyní probereme Groverův algoritmus, počínaje popisem algoritmu. Začínáme inicializací
malého n qubitů, každý do stavu plus, neboli jinými slovy dáme tyto qubity do rovnoměrné superpozice všech
binárních řetězců délky n. To, co budeme dělat, je v podstatě nasměrovat stav těchto qubitů
k řešení, takže je intuitivní, že začínáme v tomto stavu, protože o funkci f ještě nic nevíme.
V tomto okamžiku je každý řetězec stejně pravděpodobným řešením, a to se odráží ve skutečnosti, že tyto qubity jsou v rovnoměrné superpozici všech
řetězců. Poté iterujeme – opakovaně aplikujeme Groverovu operaci, která je skutečným srdcem
algoritmu, a popíši ji za moment. Tuto operaci aplikujeme celkem T krát, kde T je nějaké nezáporné
celé číslo. Toto číslo ale samotným algoritmem není specifikováno, musíme T nějak zvolit, a v další
části budeme mluvit o dobrých volbách pro T. Prozatím si lze o tomto počtu iterací T přemýšlet
jako o libovolném. A nakonec měříme ve standardní bázi, čímž dostaneme
kandidátní řešení. Není zaručeno, že je to řešení, ale pokud T zvolíme dobře, pak
pravděpodobnost získání řešení lze udělat velkou. A zde je samotná Groverova operace,
WEBVTT
kterou jsme pojmenovali G. Je to složení operací, všechny na N qubitech, takže jde o N
qubitovou operaci. Nejprve máme gate ZF, neboli jinými slovy fázový dotazovací gate pro
vstupní funkci f, následovaný vrstvou Hadamard gate, poté ZOR, což je fázový dotazovací gate pro funkci
OR, a nakonec další vrstvou Hadamard gate. Vidíme tedy, že jednu iteraci v
kroku dvě lze implementovat circuit ve tvaru zobrazeném zde na obrazovce, a zde máme mimochodem čtyři qubity,
ale obecně můžeme mít libovolný počet qubitů. Klíčová věc, které si je třeba všimnout, je, že pro implementaci G potřebujeme jeden dotaz na f –
pro implementaci ZF potřebujeme jeden dotaz a žádná z ostatních operací nezávisí na f, takže nevyžadují žádné dotazy. Takže toto číslo T,
které představuje počet aplikací G v kroku dvě, také představuje počet potřebných dotazů.
Zde je typický způsob, jak bychom mohli Groverův algoritmus používat, i když rozhodně není jediný, jak jsem
řekl dříve. První věcí, kterou musíme udělat, je zvolit T, a tomu se budeme věnovat v příští části.
Pro jakékoliv T, které zvolíme, spustíme Groverův algoritmus na T iterací a dostaneme kandidátní řešení
X. Není zaručeno, že X je skutečně řešení, ale můžeme strávit jeden další dotaz k ověření. Pokud máme řešení, pak
ho můžeme výstupovat a zastavit, jinak můžeme zkusit znovu, možná s jiným výběrem T,
ale ne nutně, nebo se vzdát a hlásit, že žádná řešení nejsou. Jak jsem řekl dříve, toto
není jediný způsob použití algoritmu, ale je to přirozený způsob jeho aplikace na vyhledávací problém. Dále uvidíme, co Groverova
operace skutečně dělá se stavem N qubitů, na které působí. Uvažujme naše n qubity jako
jeden registr, který pojmenuji Q. Pamatuj, že první věcí, kterou děláme v
Groverově algoritmu, je dát Q do rovnoměrné superpozice všech n-bitových řetězců, a to provedeme aplikací Hadamard
gate na n qubitech ve stavu samých nul. Poté iterujeme Groverovu operaci G a poté
měříme. Bude užitečné rozdělit množinu všech n-bitových řetězců do dvou množin A0 a
A1. A0 obsahuje všechny řetězce, pro které se f vyhodnotí na nulu, a A1 obsahuje všechny řetězce, pro které se f
vyhodnotí na jedničku. Jiný způsob, jak to říci, je, že A1 obsahuje všechna řešení našeho vyhledávacího
problému, zatímco A0 obsahuje všechna ne-řešení. Budeme obzvláště
zajímat o dva kvantové stavy: jeden je rovnoměrná superpozice přes všechna ne-řešení, to je ket A0, a
druhý je rovnoměrná přes všechna řešení, a to je ket A1. Měl bych upozornit, že tyto definice mají smysl
jen tehdy, když tyto množiny jsou neprázdné, protože jinak sčítáme nula věcí a dělíme nulou. A jak budeme
procházet touto analýzou Groverova algoritmu, budeme tento předpoklad dělat. Velmi snadno si dokážeme představit, co
Groverův algoritmus dělá, když f je buď konstantní nulová funkce nebo konstantní jednová funkce, tak, že je budeme tratovat jako speciální případy. Ale to
nechám na tobě. Nepřekvapivě, pokud je každý řetězec řešením, skutečně řešení
obdržíme při měření, a pokud neexistují žádná řešení, žádné nezískáme, protože v tom případě žádná
nejsou. Pro účely této analýzy ale budeme předpokládat, že obě tyto množiny jsou neprázdné, aby tyto
definice těchto dvou stavů dávaly smysl. Tato notace je mimochodem docela běžná:
kdykoli máme neprázdnou konečnou množinu S, můžeme napsat ket S pro rovnoměrnou superpozici přes
prvky té množiny, právě jak máme zde. Shromaďme tedy tyto definice a uvidíme, jak se spojují
s Groverovým algoritmem. Prvním krokem Groverova algoritmu je inicializační krok, který dá Q do rovnoměrné
superpozice přes všechny n-bitové řetězce, a abych tomuto stavu dal snadno rozpoznatelné jméno, budu ho nazývat
ket U, kde U je zkratka pro uniformní (rovnoměrný). Pro účely analýzy je důležité nejprve poznamenat, že
tento rovnoměrný stav ket U je obsažen v podprostoru rozepnutém dvěma vektory ket A0 a ket
A1. Zejména pokud vezmeme lineární kombinaci těchto dvou stavů zobrazenou zde na obrazovce, dostaneme ket
U. Klíčem k celé analýze je skutečnost, že stav Q zůstává v
tomto dvoudimenzionálním podprostoru bez ohledu na to, kolikrát Groverovu operaci aplikujeme. Takže vše se bude scvrkávat
na to, co se děje ve dvoudimenzionálním podprostoru. Podívejme se nyní, co Groverova operace dělá, a zejména co
dělá s vektory ve dvoudimenzionálním podprostoru rozepnutém ket A0 a ket
A1. Je užitečné si představit, že G je rozdělena do dvou částí: jedna je gate ZF
a druhá je gate ZOR obklopená dvěma vrstvami Hadamard
gate. Zde je definice ZF z dříve, a je poměrně přímočaré z té definice vidět, že jeho
akce na naše dva stavy – rovnoměrné superpozice ne-řešení a řešení – jednoduše přidá záporné znaménko
před ket A1. Ket A0 není nijak dotčen, a to je vše, co pro
tuto analýzu o ZF potřebujeme vědět. Pro druhou část, která je
gate ZOR obklopená dvěma vrstvami Hadamard gate, začněme připomenutím, jak je ZOR definován. Jedním způsobem, jak to napsat,
je tak, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce – jde o stejný výraz jako před chvílí, a dalším způsobem, jak to vyjádřit pomocí přímé
notace, je takto. Toto vyjádření si lze ověřit jen tím, že přemýšlíme o tom, jak operace na
pravé straně působí na standardní bázové stavy. Zejména se stavu samých nul nic nestane a každý
jiný standardní bázový stav dostane záporné znaménko, což souhlasí s definicí ZOR.
Pokud tedy tuto operaci obklopíme dvěma vrstvami Hadamard gate, dostaneme podobný výraz, až na to,
že místo standardního bázového stavu samých nul máme nyní naši rovnoměrnou superpozici ket U, a to proto, že H tenzor
n transformuje standardní bázový stav samých nul na ket U, a H tenzor n je také svým vlastním konjugovaným transpozitem, takže funguje podobně
i při působení zprava na bra místo ket. A nyní budeme zjišťovat,
co G dělá s našimi dvěma vektory A0 a A1, za použití faktů, které jsme právě
pozorovali. Začneme s A0. Nejprve dosaďme výraz,
který jsme získali pro gate ZOR obklopený dvěma vrstvami Hadamard gate. Dále můžeme použít skutečnost, že ZF nic nedělá
WEBVTT
s ket A0, takže se ZF operace zbavíme. A nyní pomocí popisu
ket U, který máme nahoře, spolu se skutečností, že ket A0 a ket A1 jsou ortogonální jednotkové vektory, dokážeme spočítat
součin tohoto bra a tohoto ket, a dostaneme odmocninu z počtu ne-řešení
děleno N. Tuto skutečnost můžeme použít k vyhodnocení toho, co dostaneme, a dosazením našeho výrazu pro ket U a
zjednodušením dostaneme konečný výsledek zobrazený zde na obrazovce. Zejména si všimni, že tento
vektor je obsažen ve dvoudimenzionálním podprostoru rozepnutém ket A0 a ket A1, jak jsem navrhoval dříve, a
navíc koeficienty jsou reálná čísla. Jako vždy si to ověř
v klidu, pokud se tak rozhodneš. V těchto videích mám tendenci takové věci rychle přechcházet s
očekáváním, že video pozastavíš a přemýšlíš o tom, pokud se tak rozhodneš. Takže to uklizme, abychom
si mohli konečný výsledek uschovat na pozdější dobu. A nyní uděláme něco podobného pro vektor ket
A1. Můžeme použít tentýž výraz G jako dříve, a tentokrát gate ZF
zavede záporné znaménko, které se zde projeví tím, že jsme prohodili dva výrazy v operaci v
závorce. Pak postupujeme velmi podobným způsobem a konečný výsledek je podobný, až na to, že dva koeficienty
jsou prohozeny a před jedním z nich máme záporné znaménko, což je jen to, jak algebra vychází. A opět si to
v klidu ověř. Všimni si, že opět máme reálnou lineární kombinaci našich dvou vektorů ket A0 a
ket A1. Uklizeme i tento a dáme konečný výsledek dohromady s tím druhým, a nyní vidíme, jak G
působí na podprostor rozepnutý našimi dvěma vektory. Jedním způsobem, jak to vyjádřit, je pomocí matice 2x2 M,
zobrazené zde na obrazovce. Aby bylo jasno, co děláme: první řádek a první
sloupec spojujeme s ket A0 a druhý řádek a sloupec s ket A1. Dosud v sérii jsme
používali matice k popisu toho, jak operace fungují na standardních bázových stavech, ale je běžné používat matice
k popisu akcí lineárních zobrazení na různých množinách vektorů, nejen standardních bázových stavů. Zde mluvíme o tom, co operace G dělá
s vektory ket A0 a ket A1. Můžeme říci více o tom, co G dělá s vektory ve
spannu ket A0 a ket A1, pokud se blíže podíváme na tuto matici M, a zejména to, co zjistíme, je,
že M je rotační matice, což znamená, že její akce na tomto dvoudimenzionálním prostoru lze popsat jako rotaci o nějaký
pevný úhel. Existuje několik různých způsobů, jak to vidět, a jedním je pozorování,
že tuto matici M lze vyjádřit jako druhou mocninu matice, která vypadá poněkud jednodušeji. To by mohlo být těžké odhalit, kdybychom se
jen dívali na M samotné, ale to není něco, co musíme sami odhalit – stačí to jen ověřit, a to uděláme jednoduše
umocněním matice na pravé straně. Jiný způsob, jak zapsat matici napravo, ne včetně mocniny,
je zobrazen na obrazovce, a jde o typický způsob popisu rotace o daný úhel théta jako
matice. Přesný úhel, o který se otáčíme, je inverzní sinus odmocniny z počtu
řešení děleno N. Mimochodem, protože to vidíme poprvé, dovolte mi upozornit, že
tento úhel je velmi důležitý a bude se stále opakovat, jak budeme pokračovat v této
analýze. Argument inverzního sinu je číslo mezi 0 a 1, a konkrétně způsob, jakým
interpretujeme inverzní sinus, je, že je to úhel mezi 0 a pí/2, který dává argument při výpočtu
sinu. To je tedy jeden způsob, jak přemýšlet o této matici, kterou jsme umocnili, abychom dostali
M. A protože umocnění matice je totéž jako její dvojnásobné aplikování, vidíme, že M lze alternativně zapsat jako
rotaci ne o úhel théta, ale o 2 násobek théta, protože umocněním otáčíme o úhel théta
dvakrát. Jiný způsob, jak to vše ověřit, mimochodem, pokud by to pomohlo, je začít s tímto posledním vyjádřením M
a použít vzorce pro dvojité úhly z trigonometrie k získání původního výrazu
M. A to je výraz M, který popisuje akci G na podprostor rozepnutý ket A0 a ket A1, který
bude nejužitečnější v dalším postupu. Nyní se vraťme k samotnému Groverovu algoritmu. Po
inicializačním kroku, ale před jakoukoliv aplikací G, je stav našeho n-qubitového registru Q roven ket U, tedy
rovnoměrné superpozici přes všechny n-bitové řetězce, a zde máme tentýž výraz ket U v pojmech ket A0 a
ket A1 jako dříve. Ale nyní, když jsme identifikovali tento úhel théta, vidíme, že
ket U bychom mohli alternativně napsat jako kosinus théta krát ket A0 plus sinus théta krát ket
A1. To je jasné pro koeficient ket A1, a pro druhý koeficient stačí pozorovat, že velikost A0 plus
velikost A1 je N, a pak to lze dostat ze základní trigonometrie. To je tedy stav, se
kterým začínáme, a při prvním aplikování G se otočíme o úhel 2 krát théta, takže celkový úhel se stane 3 krát
théta. A pokud G aplikujeme znovu, úhel se zvýší na 5 théta, protože jsme se efektivně otočili o další
úhel 2 théta, a tak dále. Takže po T aplikacích G lze stav, který dostaneme,
reprezentovat tak, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce, kde úhel našeho stavu je roven (2T + 1) krát théta – to je 2 krát théta
pro každou aplikaci G spolu s jedním dalším théta, protože to je stav, ve kterém jsme začínali.
Také si lze akci Groverovy operace představit geometricky, a to pomáhá osvětlit, jak
funguje a proč jejím efektem je rotace stavu registru Q. Zde je hlavní myšlenka: Groverova
operace je složení dvou částí, které jsme již identifikovali. Jedna je ZF a druhá je ZOR obklopený
dvěma vrstvami Hadamard gate. Tyto dvě části jsou
odrazy, a když složíme dvě odrazy, dostaneme rotaci. Podívejme se na to podrobněji.
Nejprve se zaměřme na ZF a omezme naši pozornost na
tentýž dvoudimenzionální podprostor, o němž jsme mluvili, tedy ten rozepnutý ket A0 a ket
A1. Jak jsme již pozorovali, akce ZF na tomto prostoru je poměrně jednoduchá: kat A0 se
nic nestane a před ket A1 se přidá záporné znaménko. Jde o odraz, a konkrétně
WEBVTT
jde o odraz kolem přímky rovnoběžné s ket A0, kterou budeme nazývat L1.
Proč jde o odraz, pochopíme lépe, když nakreslíme obrázek. Zde máme naše dva vektory ket
A0 a ket A1, které jsou ortogonální jednotkové vektory, a můžeme si obrazovku představit jako sestávající ze všech reálných
lineárních kombinací těchto dvou vektorů. Kruh tedy představuje všechny jednotkové vektory, pro které jsou koeficienty
těchto dvou vektorů reálná čísla. Zde je přímka L1, která je rovnoběžná s ket A0, a pokud uvažujeme nějaký
libovolný vektor S na tomto kruhu, pak efektem aplikace ZF je odraz kolem této přímky, jak je ilustrováno na
obrazovce, jednoduše proto, že ket A0 se nic nestane a před ket A1 přidáme záporné znaménko.
Ve speciálním případě, kdy S je ket A0, se při tomto odrazu nic nestane, a pokud je S rovno
ket A1, odraz nás přenese celou cestu na záporné ket A1, což je konzistentní s akcí ZF. ZF je tedy
odraz, který si lze vizualizovat tak, jak máme zde. Druhá část G, která je ZOR
obklopeným dvěma vrstvami Hadamard gate, lze vyjádřit jako 2 krát ket U bra U minus identitní matice, jak jsme
již viděli, a opět jde o odraz, tentokrát kolem přímky L2 rovnoběžné s ket U místo ket
A0. Tuto operaci si lze vizualizovat podobným způsobem jako ZF. Zde je vektor ket
U hypoteticky, takže toto je přímka L2 rovnoběžná s ket U, a opět je akcí na libovolný vektor S jeho odraz
kolem přímky, která je v tomto případě L2.
A nakonec, jak jsem zmínil dříve, kdykoli složíme dva odrazy, dostaneme rotaci, a konkrétně jde
o rotaci o dvojnásobek úhlu mezi odrazovými přímkami. Nakresleme tedy podobný
obrázek jako dříve: zde jsou odrazové přímky, mezi nimiž je úhel théta,
a pokud vezmeme libovolný vektor S, odrazíme ho kolem první přímky L1 a
poté kolem druhé přímky L2, čistý efekt bude rotace vektoru S o úhel dvojnásobku théta.
To platí obecně a můžeš to vyzkoušet na dalších vlastních příkladech, abys viděl, že to takto skutečně
funguje. Doufám, že ti to pomůže získat intuici k tomu, proč Groverova operace otáčí
vektory. Dále se budeme zabývat volbou počtu iterací T v Groverově
algoritmu. Začněme přemýšlením o tom, jak analýza, kterou jsme dosud viděli a která odhaluje, co Groverova operace dělá,
když ji opakovaně aplikujeme na rovnoměrnou superpozici, souvisí s úkolem, který doufáme splnit – najít řešení našeho vyhledávacího problému,
neboli jinými slovy libovolný řetězec obsažený v množině A1. Stručně řečeno, nastavíme si
cíl a zjistíme, kolikrát aplikovat Groverovu operaci, abychom se k tomuto cíli přiblížili.
Nejprve si představme, že máme libovolný stav, který je lineární kombinací našich dvou vektorů ket A0 a ket
A1. Pokud na tomto stavu provedeme standardní bázové měření, dostaneme výsledek v množině A1, která je
množinou řešení našeho vyhledávacího problému, s pravděpodobností rovnou absolutní hodnotě čtverce koeficientu ket A1, a pro
vektor zobrazený na obrazovce je tímto koeficientem beta. Je to intuitivní: kdybychom měřili stav ket A0,
dostali bychom náhodné ne-řešení, a kdybychom měřili ket A1, dostali bychom náhodné řešení. Takže pokud měříme tento stav
zde, dostaneme náhodné ne-řešení s pravděpodobností absolutní hodnota alfa na druhou a náhodné řešení
s pravděpodobností absolutní hodnota beta na druhou. Ale můžeme si to také prostě chvíli rozvést: zde je stav zapsaný
tak, abychom viděli, jaké jsou prvky tohoto vektoru pro standardní bázové stavy. Pokud tedy měříme, toto jsou
pravděpodobnosti pro každý možný výsledek, a abychom dostali pravděpodobnost získání řešení, sečteme
pravděpodobnosti pro všechna možná řešení, čímž dostaneme absolutní hodnotu beta na druhou,
jak se očekávalo. Nyní jsme již analyzovali, co se děje, když spustíme Groverův algoritmus na T iterací – dostaneme stav, který je
zobrazen zde na obrazovce. Protože koeficient ket A1 je sinus
(2T + 1) krát théta, kde opět platí tento velmi důležitý úhel théta, uvidíme
řešení s pravděpodobností sin² z (2T + 1) krát
théta. Rádi bychom tuto pravděpodobnost udělali velkou, ideálně co nejblíže jedné. Takže při rotaci stavového
vektoru iterací G budeme považovat ket A1 za cílový stav a budeme se snažit
vybrat T tak, abychom skončili blízko tohoto stavu. A při tom je dobré mít na paměti, že bychom také chtěli
minimalizovat T, protože to je počet dotazů, které musíme provést. Pokud tedy chceme, aby tato
pravděpodobnost byla blízká jedné a zároveň minimalizovat T, dává smysl snažit se o to, aby úhel našeho stavového vektoru byl blízký pí/2, protože
to je nejmenší úhel, který dělá druhou mocninu sinu velkou. Jde tedy v podstatě o naši první příležitost udělat pravděpodobnost velkou při rotaci
stavového vektoru. Tento úhel pí/2 samozřejmě nemusíme nutně trefit přesně, protože T musí
být celé číslo. Ale pokud o tom přemýšlíme přibližně a řešíme T jako by to bylo nerovnicí, vidíme, že ideálně
dává smysl vybrat T rovné pí/(4 krát théta) mínus 1/2.
Ale T samozřejmě musí být nezáporné celé číslo, takže co uděláme, je vzít
nejbližší celé číslo k tomu, co si představujeme jako tuto ideální hodnotu, konkrétně podlahu pí děleno 4 krát
théta. Podlaha znamená, že odhodíme jakoukoli zlomkovou část, tedy jinými slovy jde o největší
celé číslo, které je menší nebo rovno čemukoli, z čeho podlahu bereme. Podle tohoto výrazu, pokud
ideální hodnota leží přesně uprostřed mezi celými čísly, zaokrouhlíme nahoru, ale to pro tuto
lekci vůbec nevadí. Budeme se tedy soustředit na tuto konkrétní volbu
T. Je ale ještě jedna důležitá věc, kterou musíme vzít v úvahu: tato specifikace T závisí
na počtu řešení, protože úhel théta závisí na počtu
řešení. Dále budu používat písmeno s k označení počtu řešení, neboli jinými slovy velikosti
množiny A1, jen pro pohodlnost. Jde o to, že náš
výraz pro T, hodnotu, o níž předpokládáme, že by měla být dobrá, závisí na théta a théta závisí na s, což je
WEBVTT
velikost množiny A1. To není problém, pokud předem víme, kolik je řešení, ale
pokud předem nevíme, kolik řešení je, nevíme, co je théta, takže nemůžeme takto vybrat T
a budeme muset udělat něco jiného. K situaci, kdy s neznáme, se vrátím trochu později, ale začněme
se situací, kdy počet řešení známe, a to začínaje unikátním vyhledáváním,
kde je zaručeno, že hledáme jediné unikátní řešení.
Zmínil jsem problém unikátního vyhledávání jako příklad dotazovacího problému v lekci
pět. Vstupem je funkce f z n bitů na jeden bit, existuje unikátní n-bitový
řetězec, pro který se f vyhodnotí na jedničku, a cílem je výstup tohoto řetězce. Toto je tedy
ekvivalentní nestrukturovanému vyhledávacímu problému, o němž jsme mluvili, ale se slibem, že existuje právě jedno řešení. A ve skutečnosti to je
jediná verze vyhledávacího problému, kterou Lov Grover uvažoval ve svém původním článku z roku 1996, který Groverův
algoritmus představil. Pro unikátní vyhledávání máme s rovné 1, a tedy tento důležitý úhel théta je roven inverznímu sinu
odmocniny z 1/N. Když je N velké, tato hodnota je přibližně odmocnina z 1/N,
a to proto, že pro stále menší a menší úhly začíná funkce sinus vypadat stále více a více jako identita.
Pokud tuto aproximaci dosadíme do našeho výběru T, vidíme, že T je přibližně podlaha
pí/4 krát odmocnina z N. To je dobré, protože jsme na cestě k použití O(odmocnina z N)
dotazů, ačkoli v tomto okamžiku jsme ještě neposoudili, jak dobře algoritmus skutečně
funguje. Podívejme se na příklad, kde velké N je 128, což je 2 na 7. Tedy naše funkce f
je ze sedmi bitů na jeden bit a předpokládáme, že existuje unikátní řešení. Abychom ale zjistili, jak dobře
algoritmus funguje, stačí se zabývat úhlem théta, který dokážeme spočítat. Je
přibližně 0,0885 radiánu, což je trochu více než 5°, a pokud tuto hodnotu dosadíme do našeho
výrazu pro T, dostaneme osm. Přemýšlíme tedy o tom, co se stane, když hledáme unikátní řešení ze 128
možností pomocí osmi dotazů. Lze nakreslit obrázek ilustrující, jak se stav mění v čase,
jak provádíme iterace Groverovy operace. Jako dříve máme stavy ket
A0 a ket A1, a v tomto konkrétním případě – unikátního vyhledávání – je ket A1 ve skutečnosti standardní bázový stav
odpovídající unikátnímu řešení, ať je jím cokoliv. Zatímco ket A0 je rovnoměrná superpozice přes všechny
řetězce kromě unikátního řešení. Zde je rovnoměrná superpozice přes všechny řetězce, kterou
lze zapsat jako kosinus théta krát ket A0 plus sinus théta krát ket A1, a dává smysl, že ket A0
a ket U jsou si v tomto případě blízké, protože, jak jsme před chvílí pozorovali, ket A0 je
téměř rovnoměrnou superpozicí přes všechny řetězce – chybí jen jeden řetězec, a to unikátní řešení. Aplikace G znovu způsobí rotaci o
dalších 2 théta. Zde jsme po dvou iteracích, zde tři, čtyři, pět, šest, sedm a osm,
a nyní vidíme, že jsme poměrně blízko ket A1. Pokud tedy zastavíme a v tomto bodě změříme, budeme s velkou pravděpodobností
dostat unikátní řešení. A v tomto konkrétním případě je asi jen půl procenta šance, že unikátní
řešení nedostaneme. Na druhou stranu, pokud bychom pokračovali v aplikaci Groverovy operace více než doporučených osm krát,
pravděpodobnost získání řešení by šla zpět dolů a v čase by oscilovala, jak stav obíhá
kolem kruhu. Je tedy důležité, abychom iterace zastavili ve správný čas, pokud chceme uspět s vysokou
pravděpodobností. Přemýšlejme o pravděpodobnosti, že naše volba T odhalí unikátní řešení, obecněji pro různé hodnoty
N. Budeme psát pN1 pro pravděpodobnost, že Groverův algoritmus uspěje v nalezení unikátního řešení
pro každou možnou hodnotu N. Jednička znamená jedno řešení a tuto notaci brzy rozšíříme na jiné počty řešení.
Zde je tabulka těchto pravděpodobností pro malé mocniny dvou. Začíná N = 2 a
pravděpodobnost je 1/2, což není příliš dobré. Ale pro N = 4 je pravděpodobnost přesně jedna, takže v tomto případě funguje
dokonale. Je to mimochodem skvělé cvičení explicitně projít, jak tyto dva případy fungují,
zejména případ N = 4. V tom případě hledáme jedno řešení ze čtyř možností,
potřebujeme jen jeden dotaz a funguje to dokonale. Jak N roste, vidíme určité výkyvy – pravděpodobnosti trochu
stoupají a klesají – ale zdá se, že se blíží jedné, a to je skutečně pravda. Lze dokázat
analyticky, že pravděpodobnost je vždy alespoň 1 - 1/N. Takže to je dobré.
Algoritmus není dokonalý – není zaručeno, že dostaneme řešení – ale je poměrně pravděpodobné, že ho dostaneme, zejména pro velké
hodnoty N, jakož i velmi zajímavá anomálie, která nastane, když N je rovno 4.
Měl bych také upozornit, že vždy můžeme spustit celý algoritmus včetně měření tolikrát, kolikrát chceme, a pokud některé ze spuštění
uspěje, dostaneme řešení. Takže pokud tyto pravděpodobnosti nejsou dostatečně dobré, můžeme je snadno posílit pouhým opakovaným spouštěním
algoritmu. Ve skutečnosti i kdyby tyto pravděpodobnosti byly všechny rovny 1/2, stále bychom měli
užitečný vyhledávací algoritmus. Nyní uvažujme, co se stane, když existuje více
řešení. Začneme podobným příkladem jako dříve: opět N = 128, ale tentokrát je
počet řešení s roven čtyřem, nikoli jednomu. Opět dokážeme spočítat théta a T a
dostaneme, že théta je přibližně 0,1777, neboli trochu více než 10°, a T je
tentokrát čtyři. Úhel je tedy přibližně dvojnásobkem hodnoty z předchozího příkladu a T je poloviční.
Můžeme nakreslit obrázek jako dříve: zde je, kde
začínáme, zde je jedna iterace, dvě, tři a čtyři. Tentokrát jsme velmi blízko ket
A1 a pravděpodobnost získání řešení je větší než
99,9 %. Ale kdybychom nevěděli nic lepšího a mysleli si, že existuje jen jedno řešení, vzali bychom T = 8 jako
dříve, otočili bychom se téměř celou cestu kolem na záporné ket A0, a to by vedlo k velmi malé pravděpodobnosti
úspěchu. To je tedy další příklad ukazující, že existují dobré volby T a špatné volby T, a zde vidíme,
WEBVTT
že dobrá volba pro s = 1 se ukáže být velmi špatnou volbou pro s = 4. Ale za předpokladu, že s předem
víme a volíme T podle naší specifikace, ukáže se, že Groverův algoritmus najde řešení
s pravděpodobností alespoň 1 - s/N, a často bude mnohem větší. Je to také alespoň s/N, ale
to je ve skutečnosti mnohem méně zajímavé. Zajímavější je, že jak se zlomek s/N zmenšuje, horní mez
pravděpodobnosti úspěchu se přibližuje stále více a více k jedné. Jak jsem již několikrát
poznamenal, číslo T představuje nejen počet iterací Groverovy operace, ale také počet
dotazů, které provádíme. Jak tedy toto číslo závisí na s a
N? Začněme faktem, že inverzní sinus x je vždy alespoň x za předpokladu, že x je mezi 0 a 1.
To je poměrně snadné ukázat, pokud náhodou znáš Taylorovu řadu pro inverzní sinus, ale existují i jiné způsoby, jak to zdůvodnit, a my to
budeme brát jako dané, protože je to pravda. To znamená, že théta je alespoň odmocnina ze s/
N, a tedy T je nejvýše pí/4 krát odmocnina z N/
s. To je ve skutečnosti ještě lepší než O(odmocnina z N) – čím větší je s
v porovnání s N, tím méně dotazů potřebujeme. A v jistém smyslu není překvapivé, že se tento zlomek vyskytuje
takto, vzhledem k tomu, že jeho reciproká hodnota definuje théta, a na konci dne théta je skutečně jediné, na čem
pro tuto analýzu záleží. Jak jsme právě viděli, Groverův algoritmus funguje poměrně dobře, když předem víme,
kolik je řešení. Ale co když předem nevíme, kolik řešení je?
Existuje jeden poměrně jednoduchý přístup: jednoduše zvolit počet iterací
náhodně, a konkrétně výběr T rovnoměrně náhodně mezi jednou a podlahou pí/4 krát odmocnina z N se ukazuje
být poměrně dobrým způsobem. Horní hranice tohoto rozsahu je přibližně počet dotazů, které bychom volili pro unikátní vyhledávání, a ve skutečnosti
je to ve většině případů správný počet. To je případ, kdy je úhel théta tak malý, jak jen může být, s výjimkou
triviálního případu, kdy nejsou žádná řešení. Myšlenka je taková, že místo pečlivého zaměřování našeho stavového vektoru na
ket A1, jak jsme dělali, když jsme věděli, kolik řešení je, v podstatě otáčíme o náhodný úhel, jako bychom
stavovému vektoru dávali náhodný spin. Pokud náhodou existuje jen jedno řešení, náš náhodný spin by mohl
přesunout stavový vektor blízko ket A1, ale mohl by ho také posunout jen část cesty. A pokud náhodou existuje mnoho řešení,
náš náhodný spin by mohl potenciálně poslat stavový vektor kolem kruhu vícekrát. Neočekáváme tedy, že to odhalí
řešení s pravděpodobností blízkou jedné, ale šance, že to vede k řešení, pokud existuje, se ukáže být
poměrně dobrá – vždy je alespoň 40 %. To není zřejmé, ale je to
pravda. Rozhodně to ale není šokující, protože skutečně náhodný úhel by měl 50% šanci najít
řešení. 40 % není špatné a pamatujme, že vždy můžeme pravděpodobnost nalezení řešení posílit
opakováním procesu, pokaždé nezávisle volíme T. Tímto způsobem šance, že řešení
nenajdeme, přestože existuje, exponenciálně klesá s počtem opakování. Pokud tedy chceme 99% šanci najít řešení,
co lze udělat, je spustit tento jednoduchý přístup 10krát, opět s T nezávisle zvoleným pokaždé.
Přirozeně, pokud řešení nenajdeme, výstupujeme žádná řešení. Pokud žádná řešení nejsou,
žádné nenajdeme, a v tom případě vždy vydáme správnou odpověď, která je žádná řešení. Pokud řešení existují,
mohlo by se stát, že ho nenajdeme a nesprávně prohlásíme, že žádná řešení nejsou, ale pravděpodobnost, že se to stane, lze udělat velmi malou.
Také máme, jak jsem zmínil před chvílí, že to vyžaduje počet dotazů nebo vyhodnocení f, který je O(odmocnina z
N). Pomocí Groverova algoritmu tedy stále dokážeme vyřešit vyhledávací problém s vysokou pravděpodobností s O(odmocnina z N)
dotazy, i když předem nevíme, kolik řešení je. Existuje také sofistikovanější
přístup, který může vést ke snížení počtu dotazů s rostoucím počtem řešení. Nebudu ho popisovat
podrobně a raději se jen zaměřím na hlavní myšlenku. Začínáme s velkým T rovným
jedné. Poté spustíme Groverův algoritmus pro náhodný počet iterací, ale kde horní hranice je T. Takže při prvním
provedení kroku dvě spustíme Groverův algoritmus s jednou iterací, ale T se bude
zvětšovat. Pokud najdeme řešení, výstupujeme ho a zastavíme. Pokud řešení nenajdeme, zvětšíme T
a zkusíme znovu. A v určitém bodě, než T začne být příliš velké, ukončíme proces a
prohlásíme, že žádná řešení nejsou. Je to v podstatě stejná myšlenka jako v jednoduchém přístupu, kde stavovému vektoru
dáváme náhodné spiny, ale zde začínáme s lehčími spiny, kde T je
malé, pro případ, že je hodně řešení. Tímto způsobem neztrácíme dotazy tím, že stavový vektor otáčíme stále dokola
příliš silným spinem. Ale pokud to nefunguje – tedy pokud řešení nenajdeme – zkusíme znovu,
ale spinujeme trochu silněji, nebo potenciálně trochu silněji. Aby to fungovalo, rychlost
nárůstu T musí být pečlivě zvolena, a jedním způsobem, jak to zařídit, je nahradit T stropem 5/4 krát T.
T tedy roste exponenciálně a intuitivně si to lze představit jako spinování přibližně o 25 % silněji pokaždé.
Pro analýzu je důležité, že T roste exponenciálně takto. Proč 5/4, ptáš se? No, je to číslo, které funguje,
a existuje vlastně celá škála hodnot, které fungují, ale dvě nefunguje – například zdvojování T
pokaždé je příliš rychlý nárůst, aby plně využívalo výhod lehčích spinů. Každopádně, smyslem tohoto sofistikovanějšího
přístupu je, že dává stejnou asymptotickou hranici na počet potřebných dotazů jako dříve –
O(odmocnina z N/s) – ale nemusíme předem vědět, kolik řešení je. Mimochodem,
tento proces můžeme zastavit, když T dosáhne odmocniny z N, takže pokud žádná řešení nejsou, k tomuto závěru dospějeme po O(odmocnina
z N) dotazech. A to je způsob, jak zvolit počet iterací v Groverově algoritmu. Na závěr lekce
jen stručně poznamenat k Groverovu algoritmu. Za prvé, v rámci dotazovacího modelu
je Groverův algoritmus asymptoticky optimální, což znamená, že není možné přijít s
dotazovacím algoritmem pro řešení vyhledávacího problému nebo dokonce konkrétně problému unikátního vyhledávání, který by asymptoticky
WEBVTT
používal méně než O(odmocnina z N) dotazů v nejhorším případě. To lze rigorózně dokázat
a ve skutečnosti existuje více známých důkazů tohoto faktu. Zajímavé je, že to bylo známo dokonce
ještě před tím, než byl Groverův algoritmus objeven. Groverův algoritmus odpovídal již tehdy známé dolní hranici na počet
potřebných dotazů. Čas od času lidé přicházejí s přístupy, o nichž věří, že jsou asymptoticky
nadřazené Groverovu algoritmu, ale vždy je buď chyba, nebo předpoklad o funkci f a
způsobu, jak k ní přistupovat, nebo nějaký jiný problematický problém, který prohlášení vyvrací. Pokud pracuješ správně
v rámci dotazovacího modelu, Groverův algoritmus pro nestrukturované vyhledávání překonat nelze. Zadruhé, Groverův algoritmus je
poměrně široce použitelný v tom smyslu, že kvadratické urychlení, které Groverův algoritmus nabízí pro nestrukturovaný vyhledávací problém, lze
získat v různých různých nastaveních. Například někdy je možné použít Groverův algoritmus
nad jiným algoritmem a dosáhnout tak kvadratického zlepšení nad výkonem tohoto algoritmu. Groverův algoritmus je také
poměrně běžně používán jako podrutina uvnitř jiných kvantových algoritmů. Jako jeden jednoduchý příklad
lze Groverův algoritmus použít k získání kvadratické výhody nad klasickými algoritmy pro problém minimuma, který jsem zmínil v
lekci pět. A nakonec, technika použitá v Groverově algoritmu, kde máme dva odrazy
složené a iterované k rotaci kvantového stavového vektoru, lze zobecnit v poměrně
zásadním smyslu. Příkladem je technika known jako amplifikace amplitudy, kde proces,
který zobecňuje Groverův algoritmus, lze aplikovat na jiný kvantový algoritmus a v podstatě posílit jeho pravděpodobnost úspěchu kvadraticky rychleji, než
by bylo klasicky možné, a tato technika má široké využití v kvantových algoritmech. Takže může být pravda, že
Groverův algoritmus pravděpodobně nevede k praktické kvantové výhodě v blízké budoucnosti, pokud vůbec. Ale Groverův algoritmus je
bezpochyby fundamentálně důležitý a široce použitelný kvantový algoritmus, který je reprezentativní pro obecnější techniku s mnoha
využitími. A to je vše pro tuto lekci a pro tuto jednotku série, která se věnovala kvantovým
algoritmům. Probrali jsme dotazovací model a to, jak ho lze propojit s více standardním modelem výpočtů, spolu s
některými dalšími základními koncepty týkajícími se měření výpočetních nákladů. Poté jsme probrali fázovou estimaci
a faktorizaci, a nakonec Groverův algoritmus. Jak jsem již naznačil,
je toho hodně co se naučit o kvantových algoritmech, ale v této sérii přejdeme na jiné téma v příští jednotce. Zejména se podíváme
na obecnou formulaci kvantové informace, kde jsou kvantové stavy reprezentovány maticemi určitého
druhu, známými jako hustotní matice. Jak uvidíme, tato formulace se ukáže být velmi užitečnou, a dokonce
nezbytnou pro pochopení některých aspektů kvantové informace, a je to také poměrně krásné z
matematického hlediska. Doufám tedy, že se přidáš k třetí jednotce, a na shledanou
do té doby.